hi freefall why do that Margot lark
can't win I've heard this before
oh come on why you gotta be so rude no
it's a box of pain well [ __ ] Margot lar
nut and Santa will be your enemy here I
don't think I pick so right now that
I've made a more appropriate decision
let's try this again Santa is gonna be
my enemy I'm so happy for that how you
feeling big guy
cyclo whoa hey what's going on here well
pits pits are the best
I am so my dad yet oh no I'm nothing
those is my leg ow
this ball pit is hurting me quite a bit
these balls slamming into my face and
body it's not as fun as I thought it'd
be the balls betrayed me I thought the
balls with my back
all right enough ball jokes whoa hey all
right then calm down there we are always
thinking of you mark we love you so much
I love you guys too you're awesome
what is that is that an open eyes well
it's the not open eyes 5,000 who knew
that while tiny bugs Tim is the actuator
on the front oh it's so cool it's
forming it's farming sheep I'm guessing
oh man just plowing the woman of the
field I don't know if that euphemism is
quite as appropriate to selling for her
hey okay well I think this had just a
little bit too okay I'm dead well thank
you oh man thanks Caspi oh god I can't
even exit to the menu anymore it doesn't
want me to leave
whoo your mission is to clear this bar
cool good luck
well lucky
not oh [ __ ] I'm on all right okay
and I am Alive okay so where am I going
after the whoo good catch wow that
almost hurt oh you almost got me there
wait look up why you missed me ah tits
balls what is that there's so many
Impossibles ha okay well alright then
that's a great way to start out and it's
not kitties it's kitties even though
that sounds ah okay never mind
well how high oh I think I saw something
I didn't like yeah that's that's a tiny
box Tim all right Santa why don't you
just go say hi to the next area for me
thank you
alright I'll just be uh please don't
kill me markiplier marathon from the
creator of a Margaret is mount I don't
think I played that one did I maybe I
have I played whoa whoa hey whoa hey
Margalo minigame marathon I'm guessing
[Music]
I'm alive okay everything's fine
nothing's bad at all okay
well then [ __ ] all I made it
god damn I thought it wasn't gonna make
that Oh miss me
you're a dick big day
gig dammit it would be nice if I could
get to the goddamn minigames that I'm
supposed to be playing here what we do
share but everybody to be sharing a bit
about shipping ebay share but it was
shitty god damn circles share buddy Baby
Bop share buddy bibbity Bop shitty Baby
Bop shibba-dabba shibba-dabba D still
alive back there kiddo
too bad oh you're not doing well oh [ __ ]
circles I hate them don't snap my spine
oh you can snap his fight all you want
but just don't snap a mine spike trap
goody goody gumdrops what does that
supposed to mean okay now that that's
done one other nightmare awaits me well
this seems like a thing don't kill me
don't kill me no don't don't no no don't
know why why why was why why wouldst why
why why why not a cat well that's I feel
slightly threatened by this level and
you don't I got to where I was up my but
now it's these arrows up my butt seem to
have ruined my aerodynamics if you get
what I mean
it's a pun
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] what happened mistletoe for a
little bit
sans gonna go on ahead you can just let
go let go of the other little kids jack
look right there hey hey good god damn
it
gosh Gary Gary Margaret race
new okay cool okay all right well okay
cool all right this is fine I'm avid
fine me marklar level
well it seems unassuming oh no balls my
one weakness now my son took the fall
for me on the balls and I'm stuck
[ __ ] duck Jesus crisis balls
[Music]
that's much better
hey how do you level with my goddamn
legs punch oh there we go
yes I'm done with the balls not that I
know I think about anymore because I'm a
ball blown off in a [ __ ] this has been
happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video